this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by our very
own graph paper notebooks now available
in three different sizes
in the not too distant future you could
be flying
in one of these incredible planes a
configuration you've likely
only ever seen used in high-tech
military aircraft
like the b2 spirit but this plane won't
be used to carry weapons
it will be used to ferry hundreds of
passengers
around the world and use vastly less
fuel
in the process this blended wing
aircraft is capable
of causing a seismic shift in the
airline industry
greater than any other technology
advanced before it
over the past 60 years airliners have
evolved drastically
while the tried and tested tube and wing
layout
has remained largely unchanged less
obvious innovations have allowed
commercial airline travel
to become an unremarkable part of
everyday life
one statistic illustrates the continual
evolution of airliners
better than any other this graph shows a
downward trend
that has been caused by unyielding
efforts to innovate
this line represents the average fuel
burn
per passenger per kilometer engineers
have managed to find ways to reduce the
amount of fuel these planes burn
by nearly 50 percent over the past
five decades allowing travel to not only
get cheaper
but more eco-friendly per passenger
kilometer traveled
from improved wing geometries like the
eclectic mix of wingtip designs
we see across different airliners the
splice wing tips of the 737 max
the wingtip fences of the 8380 the
blended winglets of the a350
and the raked wingtips of the 787 each
design
attempts to minimize the vortex track
the drag caused by many tornadoes
forming at the end of each wing these
tornadoes cause more fuel to be burned
these wingtip devices alone can reduce
airliners fuel consumption
by up to six percent engines have of
course
undergone radical changes the most
obvious changes being the continual
increase in
engine size over time there are
uncountable
innovations and many of them are hidden
from view
however one thing really hasn't changed
all that much
in those five decades the tube and wing
has stood
the test of time the first time we saw
this format
take to the air was the boeing b-47
stratojet
in 1947. this may look to you
as a perfectly normal plane but for the
time
it was unique with a long skinny
fuselage
long and narrow swept back wings with
jet engines mounted in pods
under the wing this plane was incredibly
capable
and popular with the us military and
its success resulted in boeing investing
vast amount of money into perfecting the
format
and creating assembly lines to churn
them out
this is the template of the modern
airliner
and boeing soon used it to develop the
world's first
successful commercial jet airliner the
boeing
707 which began the tube and wings
domination
of the commercial airliner industry its
advantages made it a
difficult king to dethrone the circular
cross section
is perfect for repeated pressure cycles
as the plane rises up
and down through the atmosphere
sometimes multiple times a day
it's easy to create variants of each
plane model
by simply adding or subtracting tube
sections
to lengthen or shorten the plane this
allows aircraft companies
like boeing to quickly offer variants of
existing planes
without forcing pilots to retrain on
entirely different aircraft
and gain faa approval for an entirely
new plane
yes the tube and wing layout may be the
last thing standing between us
and truly sustainable eco-friendly air
travel
nasa boeing and airbus have all
dedicated
substantial resources into investigating
a new kind of plane
the blended wing to understand why
we need to look at some of the
disadvantages of the tube and wing
configuration
let's take a look at a typical airliner
like the 737
its center of gravity is located about
here
this is the point at which all lift will
act around
like the fulcrum on a seesaw our center
of lift is located
slightly behind this this would force
the plane to pitch downwards
without a counteracting downward force
further back on the plane
which is exactly what a horizontal
stabilizer provides
downwards force this balancing force
keeps the plane flying level but a
downwards force is
obviously not what we want we are trying
to fly
we want upwards force this is wasted
energy
at cruising speed that downward force
accounts for around five percent of the
total weight of the plane
this increases the lift the actual wing
needs to provide
which increases the induced drag the
plane is generated
and pushes the fuel consumption up
significantly
it gets worse induced drag is the drag
created as a byproduct of lift but there
is another form of drag
parasitic track which is a combination
of skin drag
and form drak with skin drag being a
function of the total surface area
of the plane and the form drag being a
function of the total frontal area
we refer to the total surface area of
the plane
as the wetted area which has its origin
in naval engineering
the wetted area referring rather
obviously
to the area of the ship underwater while
the tail is providing that downwards
force
at the cost of the wing needing to
generate additional lift
it is also drastically increasing the
plane's wetted area
the tail of a conventional airliner
accounts for between
25 and 35 of the total wetted area
this again increases fuel consumption
significantly
by eliminating the tail the blended wing
body
can benefit from a 27 decrease
in fuel consumption to put that into
perspective
if every commercial airliner became a
blended wing body
that could reduce the world fossil fuel
consumption
by 26 billion gallons a year this fuel
saving potential
has attracted the attention of every
major aerospace company
the vast majority of major improvements
in the airliner manufacturing industry
has focused around relatively minor
savings in fuel
if your plane can save an airline five
percent in fuel spend
they will choose your plane over the
competitor
imagine what a 27 decrease in fuel spend
would do
this is exactly what mcdonald douglas
was hoping for
when they started the development of
their own blended wing plane
in a hail mary play to save their
company
as sales declined as a result of strong
competition from airbus and boeing
before eventually being bought out
by boeing boeing continued their work on
the technology
alongside nasa with the experimental
x-48
the x-48 never developed into a
full-scale aircraft instead
various different sub-scale models both
powered and unpowered
were developed to investigate one very
important problem
with the blended wing aircraft stability
and control
this radical new design required the
engineers to develop
new models for control particularly
because removing the tail
removes a critical stability feature as
we explored already
the tail provides a critical service in
providing a balancing force
for the offset center of gravity and
center of lift but why can't we just
place the center of gravity
and center of lift at the same position
that would eliminate the need for a
balancing force
well that ignores the fact that planes
are constantly being knocked
out of straight and level flight by
turbulence
and the tail is constantly working to
counter these forces
to push the plane back into the desired
direction of flight
take the horizontal stabilizer as an
example
it has a negative angle of attack since
its goal is to provide
downward force to counter the forward
center of gravity
when a gust of wind knocks the plane
upwards this angle of attack
decreases and thus the downforce
decreases
allowing the weight of the nose to pull
it back down
this is why the center of gravity is
intentionally placed forward
of the center of lift as it itself acts
as a restoring force
conversely if the plane pitches down the
angle of attack
increases and increases the downforce
which forces the tail of the plane back
down the horizontal stabilizer
provides passive pitch stability
requiring
zero input from the pilot without these
stabilizing forces
a blended wing body would need constant
active course correction with control
surfaces
constantly wiggling to balance the loads
like a person trying to balance a broom
on their finger
constant tiny movements to keep the
center of mass
above the finger but a human will
eventually fail
it's not a question of if but when
this is why early attempts at flying
wings like the yb49
failed humans simply cannot reliably fly
them
then fly-by-wire technology was
introduced
and allowed unstable planes like the b2
spirit
to enter service you can see the control
surfaces
of the b2 working hard to keep the plane
flying level
in many of its refueling videos it's
possible to fly
safely like this but an active stability
control system
is always going to be less safe than a
passive one
there is very little that can go wrong
with a static
control surface like this beyond the
tail surface
breaking off which is essentially
impossible with
regular maintenance the system is
foolproof
however active stability has numerous
points of failure
the control surfaces with their various
moving parts could fail
the sensors feeding the computer with
data could fail
or the software itself can fail the one
and only loss of a b2
was caused by a failure of airspeed
sensors
which fed the control computer in
accurate data
telling the computer that the plane was
pointing downwards
so the computer responded by pitching
the plane up
at a very low speed causing the left
wing to stall
and lose lift resulting in the wing
dropping and striking the ground
thankfully the two pilots managed to
eject in time
but the loss of a 1.4 billion dollar
aircraft
is a heavy price to pay for faulty
sensors
this happened in 2008 but we have much
more recent examples of failures
and they occurred in the civilian
airline industry
the 737 max's launch was married by
failures
in fly by wire technology the 737 max
was fitted
with larger engines than its predecessor
the 737ng
these engines were fitted further
forward and higher up
as they could not fit under the wing in
the same location
without lengthening the landing gear
these new engines
and their new position altered the
flight characteristics of the plane
moving the center of gravity drastically
typically
this would be accompanied by alterations
in the airframe to ensure
passive stability but boeing in an act
of corporate greed
that i'm entirely sure the engineers in
the company objected to
decided to skip this step as it would
require the plane to be recertified
which could add years to the delivery
dates and require airlines to retrain
pilots
instead boeing installed flight software
called maneuvering characteristics
augmentation system or mcas
to automatically correct the stability
issue however
the system was designed incredibly
poorly requiring
just one sensor to display a high angle
of attack
value to activate mcas and automatically
cause the plane's computer
to take over and pitch the plane down on
two occasions
a single faulty sensor providing
erroneous data
caused mcas to force the plane into a
nosedive
this could be chalked up as an accident
caused by faulty sensors
but in reality it was faulty software
that should not have been relying on a
single sensor to trigger
engineers should expect their sensors to
break at some point
this is why redundancy in design is
needed
with multiple sensors all checking each
other's work
the archaic computers that got us to the
moon managed to do this
the fact a modern plane like the 737 max
couldn't
is criminal fly-by-wire systems
can be safe but it will require
multiple levels of redundancy and as we
saw with the 737 max
it takes only one or two instances of
failure
before the flying public will lose trust
in a plane's reputation
with a radically new design like the
blended wing
a single crash could cause the general
public to associate the design
with danger it's critical that these
systems be coded
and designed perfectly which is exactly
why the x48
models were created these models were
used to gather data
on flight performance and allow the
engineers to design
and develop new flight control
algorithms
to ensure the plane is safe these models
were designed to be scaled up to a
full-sized passenger or
cargo plane version with much of the
development
focusing on creating large internal
volumes
this layout does come with some
drawbacks the most obvious one
being the lack of windows the only
windows in the plane
will be on the main cabin door up front
this
is a bit of a bummer for those of us
that enjoy window seats
and worse still for those of us that are
claustrophobic
to alleviate this slightly designers
have proposed having high quality
cameras
feeding screens at each seat which has
been a feature already
implemented into emirates first class
cabins that aren't next to actual
windows
but i think we can all agree it's not
quite the same
while others like the flying v concept
have proposed a variation of the flying
wing design
where windows could stretch further back
along each wing
some have expressed concerns that an
emergency egress would be difficult and
slow
likely because it feels like an exit is
further away
when you can't see the outside of the
plane exit doors for the 450 passenger
version
of the plane are located in these
locations
with each of the six aisles having
emergency doors located at either
end with the short fuselage exit doors
are much closer than a traditional
airliner
and the doors are not located at an
awkward 90 degree angle to the isles
which will help prevent traffic
congestion at the turn
as people panic to get out this of
course
provided airport infrastructure changes
to accommodate them
means the blended wing will have much
faster boarding and deboarding times
we have all been there when a single
person manages to clog
the only exit aisle as they dither
around with their backs
with six aisles no one person can stop
the entire plane from deboarding
this layout with a much wider and
shorter fuselage
comes with some fantastic structural
benefits too
a typical tube and wing aircraft spreads
the internal volume
over the length of the aircraft so if we
map where the weight is located
along the lateral y-axis of the aircraft
it would look something like this the
vast majority of the weight of the
aircraft is centered in the fuselage
now if we map where the lift is located
it would look something like this
with the vast majority of the lift being
located over the wings
this is a problem because this
introduces bending stress
at the root of the wings where the
downward force of the fuselage
meets the upwards force of the wings to
withstand this bending
stress tube and wing planes need to add
a significant amount of structural
reinforcement
this adds weight and thus once again
increases fuel consumption now let's
look at the cross-section of the
proposed
full-scale 450 passenger version
of the x-48 this layout with a much
shorter and wider fuselage
results in a weight distribution that
would look something like this with the
weight
much more evenly distributed along the
y-axis of the aircraft
now if we map the lift distribution it
would look something like this
with the lifting body fuselage actually
contributing to the total lift of the
plane
this means that our lift and weight are
largely located
over the same areas reducing airframe
stresses
dramatically with up to 50 percent lower
bending loads
this means the plane can reduce the
reinforcements required
to resist these loads and thus total
weight
this lift distribution is also near the
optimum to minimize the induced drag
caused by vortices
forming at the wing tips this occurs as
a result of high pressure air
under the wing mixing with low pressure
air above it
by creating an elliptical lift
distribution
this undesirable mixing is minimized
once again
reducing fuel consumption however there
is one problem
it's difficult to design this internal
fuselage
to resist pressure loading as the plane
rises
through the atmosphere the air outside
the plane
lowers in pressure while we pressurize
the inner cabin
to a comfortable level for the
passengers this causes an internal
pressure that causes the fuselage to
expand
the circular fuselage of the tube and
wing is the optimal shape
to resist pressure circular pressure
vessels expand equally
in all directions and thus the skin of
the fuselage
is primarily in tension equally around
the circumference
with square interiors like this the
pressure would cause the roof to balloon
outwards
with large deflections in the mid-span
between bulkheads
and stress concentrations at the
bulkheads between each cabin section
this is not ideal we have already seen
what happens to planes when repeated
pressure cycles
are combined with stress concentrations
like this
the very first video on this channel
discussed the problems with the de
havilland comet
an early jet airliner which featured
square windows
these windows allowed stress
concentration to build around the
corners of the window
which over repeated pressure cycles
allowed cracks to gradually form
as a result of metal fatigue this caused
three fatal mid-air disintegrations of
the fuselage
before the problem was identified and
fixed by
changing the windows to an oval shape
and reinforcing the area
around them designing a pressurized
aircraft
like the x-48 with standard aluminium
would be incredibly cumbersome and would
require intensive inspections and
maintenance
to ensure no dangerous cracks were
forming however
thanks to some modern manufacturing
techniques we can design a plane like
this with
relative ease carbon reinforced plastics
are the future of airliner manufacturing
we've already seen the benefits this
material has provided the 787
its fuselage is formed by wrapping a
carbon fiber tape
around a fuselage mold this is then
placed inside an autoclave oven
to cure a plastic resin that will bind
the carbon fibers together
to form one solid structure thanks to
the stiffness and strength afforded by
the carbon fibers
the 787 can pressurize the interior to a
much higher level
a pressure equivalent to about 6 000
feet in altitude
a typical airliner has air pressure
equivalent to about 8
000 feet if you've ever felt bloated on
a long journey
the lower air pressure is why because
your stomach is literally expanding
due to the lower outside pressure the
lower air pressure
also decreases the amount of oxygen your
body can take in
which exacerbates the effect of jet lag
you may have also noticed the
absolutely massive windows on the 787
these huge windows create large stress
concentrations
in the fuselage but thanks to carbon
reinforced composites
relative immunity to fatigue the
engineers were able to make them bigger
without worry of crack growth causing
failures
so the key to building the x-48 will
undoubtedly be
carbon composites the designers of the
x-48
proposed two potential structures to
deal with this internal pressure cycling
the initial concept proposed separating
the skin
from the pressure vessel allowing the
pressure vessel to be shaped with arches
between
bulkheads the other design simply called
for a thick
composite sandwich structure that would
act as both the skin
and the pressure vessel ultimately the
second design was preferable
as any breach in the inner arch pressure
vessel
could cause the thinner outer skin to
break away completely
and thus the outer skin on this design
would also need
to be capable of resisting the internal
pressure making the internal pressure
vessel
entirely redundant we have plenty of
experience in designing a plane with
these kind of materials now
in fact the b2 was primarily constructed
from a carbon graphite composite
which not only allowed the engineers of
the b2 to precisely mold the plane
to the optimum shape to scatter incoming
radar
but the material itself absorbs more
radar waves
boeing was the primary subcontractor for
the construction
of the b2 manufacturing much of the
aircraft's skin
using an automated tape laying process
which they now use for the 787
this process will allow manufacturers to
optimize the shape of future blended
wings
and incredibly will result in a plane
with far
fewer parts than a traditional airliner
up to 30 percent
fewer parts which after initial
investments in creation of new
manufacturing tooling
should result in cheaper planes one
impressive example of this in
action is the northrop grumman bat
surveillance drone
developed by swift engineering whose
fuselage consisted
of just three parts an upper skin a
lower skin
and a payload cover just three moles
required to build an entire fuselage
is incredibly impressive and cost
effective
it's clear that the technologies needed
to facilitate the introduction of a
commercial blended wing
have reached maturity up until now the
incentive to invest
vast amount of money into a new airframe
was low
but that may soon change aeronautical
engineers have seen the potential of
blended wings
for over seven decades with potential
benefits like 15 percent
lower total takeoff weights and 27
percent lower fuel consumption
over traditional airliners it's clear
why the idea
has never truly been forgotten the final
push
the industry needs to finally adopt the
blended wing
may come with the need to eliminate
hydrocarbon fuels
altogether as we learned in our previous
episode
engineers are struggling to find space
within the airframe
of tube and wing planes to incorporate
hydrogen fuel tanks
but blended wings with massive internal
volumes
and low fuel consumption would make this
job
vastly easier if hydrogen fuel wins the
battle to replace fossil fuels
in the aviation sector there is no doubt
in my mind that we will soon be seeing
these futuristic planes landing in
airports all
around the world richard walls one of
nasa's strategic technical advisors
for advanced aircraft even stated we
could soon see these planes in service
by 2040 ushering in a new era of air
travel
as i was researching this topic i came
across a lot of new information i wasn't
familiar with
it takes me time to absorb and
understand new topics like this
and my method for learning has always
centered around
taking meticulous notes with carefully
drawn diagrams
the process helps me slow down and focus
on the information i'm taking in
instead of just blindly reading to me
this almost meditative process is
critical
to creative learning not just reading
and memorizing what you learned
but truly understanding it and
incorporating it
into the creative kaleidoscope of your
mind
where new coherent ideas form seemingly
at random
to me this is the core of what
engineering is about
the junction of science and art and
every artist needs the right canvas we
started with
just the moleskin style notebook two
years ago
but since so many of you have been
repeat customers
as you fill in these notebooks with
college notes we wanted to offer a
larger
college notebook version it's larger and
has more pages
all lined in a metric one centimeter
grid i designed it with the spiral on
top
to allow you to use the spiral bind to
shield your precious notes
as you attempt to shove the notebook
into a crammed backpack
we are currently doing a bundle where
you can get both the college notebook
and moleskin style notebook together
with
a free pocket-sized field notes version
thrown in for free and on top of that
you will get a free month of nebula with
every purchase
so you can watch my original logistics
of d-day series
for free along with all the other
wonderful
original content on nebula a link for
that
is available on screen right now and in
the description
if you are looking for something else to
watch right now you could watch my last
video about the uncertain future of jet
fuel
or watch real science's latest video
about the rise of hybrid animals in the
[Music]
wild